there are some in south africa
who think this is a political protest
but there were no placards on display in
the township
of alexandra instead we witnessed a
battle for control
waged by police officers using tear gas
and rubber bullets
and hundreds of rioters who had taken
the opportunity
to plunder and this small detachment
were hopelessly outnumbered
unable to clear the area the police
pushed out
then retreated as the looters grabbed
what was
left on the shelves everything in this
shopping mall of any value
has been removed over the course of one
furious evening but there are still
people
picking through the ruins looking for
anything of value
they can find it and this game of
cat and mouse comes with terrible risks
down on watt street there was a man
lying motionless on the pavement
one of six people to lose their lives
since the violence began
jose pastana is a butcher and this was
his shop
it's a disaster it's like everyone lost
you know yeah
everyone the most of the shop there's no
shop left here there's no pizzas there's
nothing left here
these disturbances were triggered last
thursday after the arrest of the
country's former president
jacob zuma at his home in kwazulu-natal
[Music]
what began as a series of demonstrations
in that province
has turned into something far more
unpredictable
shops and shopping malls have been
ransacked
or destroyed and lorries on the highway
between durban and johannesburg
have been torched the government
says it's now ready to bring in the army
jacob zuma was sentenced to 15 months
after he refused to participate
in an inquiry into corruption during his
presidency
he handed himself over to police last
week
but his supporters remain loyal
describing him
as a prisoner of conscience
yet the majority will view these events
as unconscionable
although there's a danger they could
spread in a country that has been
badly hit by the pandemic millions of
south africans lack employment
the police have made hundreds of arrests
but the effect
has been decidedly limited john sparks
sky news in johannesburg